je regarde des fois sur Marketplace puis
il y a des téléphones à vendre à des
prix intéressants claire Lavoie de
Gatineau a trouvé toute une aubaine un
iPhone 13 pro max flambant neuf à 700
dollars de rabais j'ai dit pourquoi tu
le vends et dis mon cousin qui me le
donner puis moi je n'ai pas besoin elle
accepte l'offre puis se rend chez son
fournisseur de téléphonie c'est là qu'on
lui apprend que son téléphone est un
faux c'est assez impressionnant c'est
très très bien fait pour Tarek Safa de
la boutique fixipro aucun doute c'est un
téléphone Android bas de gamme ne
fonctionne pas ici on a un clavier
Android à l'intérieur aucun composant ne
provient d'Apple il y a juste une caméra
qui est vrai et les autres c'est des
deux fausses caméras c'est un faux
produit importé de la Chine le
commandant Steve Belzil connaît bien la
fraude de faux iPhone à Montréal
seulement le service de police traite
175 dossiers similaires par an un livre
fraudeurs comme tel ça peut partir de
l'âge de 14 ans dans Jeune 20 ans des
souvent ils vont utiliser un faux profil
nous avons trouvé des faux iPhone en
vente dans plusieurs villes canadiennes
dont celui-ci la couleur noire ou black
n'existe pas pour les iPhone 13 pro max
on devrait plutôt lire graphite nous
donnons rendez-vous à la vendeuse parce
que vous savez que vous avez un faux
rendez-vous
comme prétexte c'est que ils ont reçu
deux téléphones en cadeau qui veulent
partir parfois de petits détails peuvent
mettre la puce à l'oreille le type chez
Vidéotron en fait remarqué que les 54
c'est un S14 et non 54 donc en fait une
faute de frappe c'est une fausse facture
définitivement puisque les offres sont
alléchantes il faut se questionner il
faut vérifier madame Lavoie apporté
plainte à la police mais il a peu
d'espoir de récupérer son argent 2000$